the press is pushing a totally and
intentionally deceptive statistic about
school shootings compiled by the gun
control group every town for gun safety
the group claims that since the new year
were only less than a month in there
have been 11 school shootings in this
country so why haven't you heard about
them well naturally it's because most
aren't school shootings at all
two of them were suicides one was an
accident when shooting was a BB gun
being fired at a school bus window and
so on none of it good but those aren't
school shootings
despite the lying the shooting count has
been repeated by the New York Times by
CNN NPR and many other outlets they used
to take seriously because they tried to
get their facts right dinner ash is a
radio show host and a spokeswoman for
the NRA and she joins us tonight so
that's well first let's I wonder if the
stats are so they say there been 11
school shootings how many school
shootings have there been do you know
well and Tucker thank you thank you so
much for having me here's the crazy
thing about how they define a school
shooting and that they try to say that
this is how the FBI describes mass
shootings but the FBI Tucker doesn't
actually use the phrase mass shooting
what they use is mass murder or mass
killing and even then they still have a
numerical value assigned to that so the
FBI doesn't consider something to be a
mass murder or mass killing unless
you're looking at four or more
individuals having been killed and that
does not include the perpetrator that
does not include the individual who was
there killing into other people right
and so when you look at the numbers that
are being pushed by every town which has
done this over and over again for year
after year after year that's in no way
accurate now as you were saying there
have been school shootings this year and
it's awful they are rare unlike what you
hear repeated often in media and what
you've seen in headlines they are rare
they do not occur often but they do get
a lot of media coverage because it's a
it's a scary thing and this is what this
group is wanting to do they want to
exploit that and Bank on that as a way
to inspire fear in everyone so that they
can then push a policy position and they
can as you noted fundraise off of that
particular that fear
mongering and it's just it's just simply
not accurate the stuff that they've done
and Tucker I want to note as well
because you mentioned all of the other
media outlets that have repeated this
back in 2014 every town which is a
subsidiary of Mayors Against Illegal
Guns and moms demand it's one of those
it's one of those Bloomberg groups
they've done this before
now in fact Washington free beacon and
Steven Bukowski who's written a
fantastic article about the latest list
that they've that they put out they've
done this before wherein they compiled a
list of all of these what they say were
school shootings and Tucker you know you
mentioned in this latest list
they were including incidents which
again still bad but it's not a school
shooting it's not a mass killing where
someone fired a BB gun and it hit a bus
window now the what the list that they
came out with in 2014 I went through
this I actually included it in my first
book hands off my gun
they included gang activity that wasn't
actually on school property but was near
a school they included an argument
between two grown men who were unrelated
to a school it happened in a school
parking lot they were arguing over
gambling one of them shot the other bad
but that does not qualify as a mass
killing as noted by the FBI of course
none of it is good but she shouldn't lie
about it I mean that's the point facts
matter and I appreciate that you've
assembled those facts that are honest
autumn day thank you thank you Tucker